guys I made a huge mistake I went on the
dark dark web the dark web dark dark web
dark web block web of the dark web but
it's not my fault I was roped into it by
another youtuber he put very scary in
the title I was curious
what can I say I wanted to know more I
ended up buying a package from the dark
web and I will unbox it at the end of
this video but first let's go through
what inspired me to do this
[Music]
okay guys we just got up sorry okay I'm
already nitpicking but I just noticed
this it's open you don't need to cut it
again
it's open it's 100% open look at that
he's cutting nothing Oh
[Music]
anyway let's watch the video okay guys
we just got it open damn he actually got
it open that must have been really
tricky cuz whoever sent it to him
through the dark web did a great job
packaging it with the regular home table
yo what's going on guys welcome back to
the channel what's going on guys every
youtuber in 2018 the same person just
slightly different I mean yeah obviously
well if you guys have been keeping up
with the previous videos you guys know
about this whole entire Angeles
situation guys well of course who
doesn't know by the angelus situation
everyone is talking about it's like the
Shane Dawson series every youtuber is
discussing this thing
Angela doll has still not shown up guys
I have no idea where the hell it went
since we played that one-man
hide-and-seek guys I'm sure it's gonna
turn up eventually but guys it's been
like three days now and I still have not
seen it so I guess until it shows up
guys we cannot make any more videos
about it guys the Angelina situation is
totally out of control
I know you guys really want to see this
Angelina thing and guys like I'm trying
to not drag out this video at all for
you guys oh I was if to entertain you
guys and make sure I get the best
possible content for you guys you're
gonna want to go watch the previous four
videos on the channel guys I'm gonna go
away take my chances on that one okay I
think I'll just watch this one three
weeks ago I ordered this dark web
mystery box guys for about a thousand
dollars Oh a thousand dollars sure I
like how he just probably put some prize
on a nice $1000 I ordered it the picture
of what it looked like it looks
absolutely crazy guys even crazier when
I saw it in real life but basically
inside of him Jesus Christ just get on
with it alright so basically this guy
bought a package from the dark web
you've probably seen these videos in
your
Tabb if not don't click on them they're
never anything interesting I saw one
where it said I bought a hard drive from
the dark web and guess what it was just
a hard ride buying a hard drive for
their dark web oh wow it was an actual
hard drive Oh spooky it's a cursed hard
drive because it's from the dark web
basically the dark web guys is this
website that can only be accessible from
a special type of browser guys if you
want to know more about it then just go
search it up on Google it literally
tells you how to do it all but I
definitely I like how this guy tells me
how to Google things if you guys want to
know how this work this is website
called Google and you can just look it
up yourself so if you want to know about
that just google it what the dark wet is
not to be played around this is where
all the negative evil happens got to
basically run all the negative evil
stuff is from the dark web believed the
dark web is coming over ah energy did
you see the chair move run by this evil
cult and it's where all illegal things
happen but on it's where all evil things
happen prices range from anywhere from
$10 to like $10,000 guys three weeks ago
I ordered one that was worth like a
thousand dollars so I'm not gonna be
able to afford to do that again for this
video I know you guys so in this video
he did the budget version of that dark
red box I can't wait to see what's
inside
what could the dark web send us just a
bunch of curse items it says in the
title it's cursed check it out it
literally oh my god
the W I don't even know oh you know what
that stands for the dark web that is
this guy literally took a moving box
it's not even a shipping box it's one of
those moving boxes and he wrote dark web
on it so he could go on camera
whoo I think you know what I think that
means dark web I'm running through this
a bunch of people and we all come up
with the idea that it probably stands
for dark web it's so freaking crazy
check it oh god you didn't you see
anything in there
I am so nervous to get this open guys
you know what happened the last time I
open one of these things it did not end
go just before we get into actually
unboxing this dart web mystery box make
sure you go down below and drop a like
on this course of course you can't watch
a video with that and I say it every
video but go down below and hit that
subscribe button for oh my god okay
alright okay just open the box as you
turn on the post notification we got a
friend on the post notice I'm trying to
skip past it and it just gets more holy
crap guys we're gonna actually do this
right now this is pretty freaking crazy
I got my knight ready to cut the tape
open ways.i knife from the dark web
there's definitely something in there
like I'm glad he bought a package online
and it had something in it that's always
nice that would have been epic troll if
it was just a box
oh alright guys I just managed to get
dark web box open and I forgot to
mention in the intro that when I ordered
this on the Deep Web it said something
in the description about it being like
from Egypt or it was like some Egyptian
ancient I like that he you have to throw
some extra lore in there okay guys I'm
just gonna have the camera set up like
this while we actually unbox this video
holy crap guys based on the first look
inside this the stuff in here is looking
like it's worth a lot of money guys like
okay so he's he's peaked in the box and
he's had a quick evaluation and he's
come up with the consensus that it's
worth a lot of money in there okay I'm
curious to see what got maybe like a
bunch of gold or something crap there is
a lump wow that looks like he's worth a
lot of money he was not kidding huh what
did we got damn you know I don't wanna
jump right into this guys I'm just gonna
reach my grab the first thing we feel I
like that he saw that it was a knife in
there and then he decides you know what
I'm not even gonna look what the hell is
Rick what holy crap holy it looks like
moly that looks like something you could
just buy from CVS in the Halloween
section and it's October right now
my god the Egypt's the ancient eve just
must have copied us what are the odds
some sort of like it looks like one of
those cops like were you freakin poor
that looks like one of those cups where
he is he trolling he has to be trolling
I know he's pandering to children but
the words he use are just so moronic
that I can't tell if he's deliberately
putting them in there as a joke or if he
just doesn't know how to articulate
himself
this guy's holy crap it looks like some
sort of like it looks like one of those
cops like where you freaking pour the
blood in and the people like I evil cult
drinks out of it guys it's got like a
creepy freaking skull face on the front
oh my god I wonder who has touched that
you had you touched it more importantly
I wonder what it's worth I'm trying to
get my money back from buying this guy's
hope I wonder what it's worth well this
is a crazy coincidence but you can also
buy them for three pounds guys this is
frickin crazy
they're also selling them in China but
he said they got him from Egypt this is
very scary oh my god I wonder who had to
touch that some Chinese worker that
suits touched it
guys I feel like there's secretly like a
freaking old rat living in this box and
it's gonna like bite my finger off okay
whoa what the hell is this it's a Gucci
cat oh my god
guys this looks like Oh cuz the you guys
remember I was saying the Box had some
like sort of Egyptian thing in the
description I don't know about you guys
but this looks like some sort of
Egyptian thing guys look at this guy
it needs to be a detective I mean first
of all he uncovered the secret of the
text where a DV stands for dark web and
then he connected that the Egypt object
had something to do with the fact that
he ordered it from an Egyptian curse
thing oh my god anyone's Egyptian in the
comments and can tell me what this says
that would be greatly appreciated that
is freaky even strongly himself
recognize that that's beyond his level
you know hey guys we're an Egyptian
leave a comment down below where you
think these hieroglyphics mean
we're Swedish just let me know what
these Nordic ruins means I would greatly
appreciate it as you all know ancient
languages one of my favorite objects is
of course the knife that he just added
in there for extra effective spookiness
I guess he looked at the box that he
with all the stuff that he bought from a
Halloween store and thought well not
spooky enough we need to add a knife in
there but the best part about it is his
comment about that there's a knife in
name oh my god there's something sharp I
think I just cut myself what the hell
guys the freaking night guys I literally
have a knife exactly like this that's so
weird what are the odds I like how he
does this just in case some cynical
ten-year-old is watching this be like he
can just go whoa it looks just like it
whoa it looks just like the kitchen
knife I had I just got the chance this
is another genius observation coming up
by the way what is this Oh guess in the
comment what he's going to guess what
that Abe's
my gosh guys it looks like a freaking
rope skies
this guy's too next Sherlock Holmes it
looks like a frickin rope guys okay I
don't even want to say what I think this
might have been used for guys but that's
pretty weird a frickin rope and it's
like one of those old ropes guys like
holy crap that I never heard of those
old bro
this goes on for ten more minutes
whoa it's that a real skull guys okay
for those of you that are freaked out
this
okay what is it does not look like a
real skull Oh
oh thank god oh thank god oh but I
wonder what the hell this was used for
guys and why it's in the box this is
pretty frickin creepy guys yeah I wonder
what I would was used for but most
importantly I wonder how much he's worth
I want to make sure he makes his money
back on this look at that look at that
that is so creepy he's got a ball what
is this it's real guys we found some
like it's a beard looking ball you found
a ball this is too good what else do we
got
what is this
oh my god okay I don't even want to
touch that I think you guys can already
assume what the hell that was your mom's
tampon Oh goes forever it goes forever
holy crap
all right guys we found some like weird
dark chains wait a minute that's the
chain from the other and if you guys are
thinking oh that's the chain from the
other mystery box it's literally not
guys like you can go compare the colors
this one is like a dark
oh damn it he got me you're right that
one is darker that chain is darker from
the other one he also has some letter
dark web box and the paper looks pretty
new guys like it's not an old paper it
looks like he was literally just printed
right as it was being shipped you mean
write us you just put it in the box it
also has the exact same point as he used
in another stupid video I don't know why
I'm even trying to prove him or whatever
okay I don't need to do this but the
most important part of this is I ordered
a box from the darkest web
I paid not just a thousand I paid ten
thousand so I hope I get my monies back
we're gonna unbox it right now
so I got this this is the box that I got
from so this is the box that I got from
the Deep Web guys it arrived just this
morning and he says wait a minute it
says death the pantry
what the Frick guys what does that stand
for what does that even mean that much
it means something death like dining
dice am I gonna die from opening this
okay guys we're gonna have to freakin
unbox this right now but if I die you
have to smash like on this video right
now whoa holy crap guys it's got this
whoa oh my god goes forever you got this
wrapping plastic in it it must be some
cursed wrapping Constance filled with
demons or some maybe that's like a ghost
whoa oh my gosh guys oh it's got a doll
in it this must be some kind of cursed
frog oh my gosh no way no way a kitchen
whisker machine thing guys this is just
like the one I have in my house this
must be some ancient demon trapped in a
box oh my god guys it's trying the demon
is trying to kill me it's time for
random shout-out time random shout-out
time this time it's actually not so
random I found this video thanks pretty
cool he does great videos I really enjoy
his channel he's always finding new
interesting things for me to steal from
I was also part of one of his podcasts
that he does is really great as well so
if you want to check that out
I'll leave that in the description but
overall just a nice great dude that I
don't really know just assuming and also
to Strama D if you're watching I hope
you enjoyed this little video I'm sure
you did just a fun little meme I can't
wait to see what happens with the doll
so good luck with that
bye